Generals in Gabon gathered to pray for
the success of bris uligi in guema the
general that took down the 55-year-long
Bongo Dynasty after staging a coup on
Wednesday and gwema arrested Ali Bongo
after he was announced the winner of
Saturday's presidential elections
the coup sparked celebrations in the
capital
is
spelled the end of all the killings that
my forefathers parents and I have
experienced this is all now over
for the last 50 years we have been ruled
by a bunch of gangsters that pillage the
country's resources and have made our
people Beggars
our elders get afford Healthcare young
people are unemployed the situation has
just gotten worse for a country that's
so rich
six billion dollars worth of crude oil
were exported last year Gabon is a
country rich in natural resources where
most live on less than two dollars a day
the Junta have accused bongo's family of
high treason accusing them of stealing
billions from State coffers meanwhile
the African Union has expelled Gabon the
UN and the EU including France the
former colonial power have condemned the
coup
we would like to reassure all donors
development Partners as well as state
creditors that all Provisions will be
taken to guarantee respect for our
country's commitments both externally
and internally
and gwema is expected to be sworn in as
president of transition on Monday by the
Constitutional Court this once trusted
Confidant of The Bongo family and France
appears to some a continuation of the
past it is an Insider the regime so it
shows that this is somebody who
understands the inner workings of the
regimes particularly within an apparatus
as strategic as the defense and security
sector
the political opposition and Civil
Society members call on the Junta to
complete the vote count saying the
presidential elections were marred by
fraud
and grandma is seeking to unite the
country for his supporters the coup is
an opportunity for a new beginning in a
country that has lost trust in its
leaders Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera